MALE SPEAKER: So yeah,
this is going to be a quiz.
So if you're not on the Wi-Fi,
get yourself on the Wi-Fi now.
The username and
password is on there.
And then once you've done that,
if you want to go to this URL
and make up your own
username and password.
Obviously not the same username
and password, or a bunch of you
will be on the same account.
You won't be able
to get to that URL
if you're not on that Wi-Fi
network, so make sure you are.
And if you're watching this on
the live stream, tough luck,
I'm afraid.
You've just got to play
along using your brain.
And you can write
things down on paper
and score yourself if you want.
The reason I'm asking you
for a username and password
is just so you can switch
devices halfway through in case
your phone starts
running out of battery,
and you want to
switch to your laptop.
Just use the same
username and password,
and everything will work.
The password is stored in
plain text on my machine.
So don't use your credit
card number or anything
like that unless you're
intending to make a donation,
and that will be gratefully
received, thank you very much.
I'm going to assume
everyone's ready to go.
I will keep the URL in
the corner of the screen,
so if anyone loses it, you'll
be able to pick it back up.
I hacked this
together on a plane.
You could probably break
it by trying to break it,
so please don't
try and break it.
I've made it so little
Bobby Tables can play.
That's not going to break it.
But there are
probably other things.
You could probably doss it,
so please don't do that.
And I want to stress that
this quiz is pretty tough.
I've seen it get
the better of people
who do this kind of study of
browser quirks for a living.
So if you're the kind of
person who gets really angry
and starts flipping over
tables when you don't win,
then just maybe stay away from
the tables for a little while,
OK?
Of course, what
kind of a quiz would
be complete without a prize?
The Chromebook Pixel is
Google's latest laptop
featuring an I5 1.8 gigahertz
dual core processor,
four gigabytes of RAM, and
a touch screen with a higher
DPI than a MacBook Pro.
Couldn't get hold
of one of those.
Sorry.
They wouldn't let me.
But what I did get
is a Chromecast
so I've got one of
those to give away
for whoever gets
the highest score.
So it's not quite a Pixel,
but it's very, very good.
So let's start.
Let's start off really simple.
And so the URL's there on
the bottom of the screen
if you need it again.
But here's a nice, easy start.
You've all worked with
images in HTML, right?
OK, so here's a div, but it has
a source like an image might.
Which browsers do
you think are going
to make a request
for that image?
Now, on your phones
or on your laptops,
you should be presented
with the options.
So you pick which ones you think
are going to make a request,
and then hit "submit."
If it's not appearing
on the screen,
or the icons aren't, you can
just give the page a refresh,
and that should come through.
When we're talking
about these browsers,
I mean the latest versions of
each one, so IE 10, et cetera.
You get one point if you get it
right for a particular browser.
You lose a point if you get it
wrong for a particular browser.
So there's a maximum of
four points per question
and a minimum of minus 4.
You can score negatively.
You can assume the
HTML5 doc type,
and there's nothing
hidden going on.
I'm not going to
turn round and say,
oh but there's a base
element that's changing URLs.
There'll be none of that.
It's just what's there on
the screen, that one line.
What we're seeing here is a live
opinion of the room as well.
So the needle swings one way
when you're saying collectively
that yes, the browser
will make a request.
It'll swing the other
way if you're saying no.
But I'm going to
randomize which way
is yes and no for each
question, so you can't just
look at the screen and
vote along with the room.
OK, that's probably enough time.
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
OK, we can see from
this that you're
saying Chrome is going
to make a request here.
You're less sure about
the other browsers.
And the answer is no.
None of the browsers is going
to make a request in this.
But it's not actually
as mad as it seems.
This doesn't work in HTML5,
but it was proposed in XHTML2.
XHTML2 allows you to do
this: put a source attribute
on anything, and it
would replace the content
with what you had in the source.
And this is really
good, because it
meant that the old attribute
on the images became redundant,
because you could replace
real semantic content.
Pretty cool idea, but XHTML2
was backwards incompatible,
and it carried with it XML's
draconian error handling.
And once you invite XML into
your home, it XML's everything.
XMLs all over the
floor, up the walls.
And in the same way that Smurfs
stick the word "Smurf" in front
of everything to make
it a Smurf thing,
XML does it with X. You don't
want HTML, you want XHTML.
You don't want frames,
you want Xframes.
You don't want forms,
you want Xforms.
If you let XML take
over your life,
it will turn your
boyfriend or girlfriend
into an ex-boyfriend
or girlfriend.
And XML's cool with
that, because you
don't need a partner any more.
You've got XML to
look after you.
It seems fitting
that in 2009, XHTML
became an ex-specification, and
it was completely abandoned.
And no browsers ever implemented
that source attributes
on elements other than
images and the things
they work on now.
OK, but what about this?
Here we've got an image element.
It's got a source.
It's in the page, but I've
spelled "image ' incorrectly.
I've put it I-M-A-G-E
rather than I-M-G.
Does the browser treat
it as an unknown element,
or does it make the request?
The browser only has
to make the request.
It doesn't have to
display it on the page,
in case you think that matters.
XML was too strict
to work with the web,
but is HTML best lenient?
Or are the browsers more
lenient than the spec?
Just get your
answers in quickly.
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one,
and it's closed.
So we're edging towards
no in all of the browsers.
All the browsers will make
a request for this image,
and they will display it.
Because in the past, a browser
decided that I-M-G is quite
difficult for
developers to remember,
so they should support
I-M-A-G-E as well.
And we've been stuck
with it ever since.
Which browser
engine do you think
we've got to thank for this?
Yep, you've guessed it.
It is Mosaic back in 1993.
The people who
invented the image tag,
they put this alias in.
And a study in 2005 showed
that 0.2 percent of pages
were using this
misspelled image tag.
So any browser that
wants to work on the web
that we have today has
to duplicate this alias.
The WHATWG recognized this,
and they added it to the spec.
This is the parsing spec.
Start tag, name image,
change the token to IMG,
and reprocess it.
Don't ask, which is great.
But this was actually used
in a clever hack recently.
Alexei10 came up with
this, which I really liked.
You would use this in place
of your image elements.
What it does is it loads an SVG,
for browsers that support SVG,
and it loads a PNG for
browsers that don't.
So the way a modern browser
would parse it is it sees SVG,
and it goes OK, it's got a
width and height of 100%,
so about 100 pixels.
And it sees this,
and this is a-- it
sees this as an SVG image
element. 'Cause in SVG, images
are spelled out full,
rather than IMG.
It's got a width and a height,
and I'm going to load this.
Because this is how you define
the source of an image in SVG.
Because why have links
when you could have Xlinks?
And then it sees this, and
that doesn't mean anything
to SVG images, so it's ignored.
So we're now showing
the SVG image.
An older browser such as
Android 2 or IE8 and below,
they will parse it like
this: No idea what that is.
I'm going to ignore it.
I'm going to treat it
like an unknown element.
Oh look, the developer has
spelled "image " wrong.
It's OK.
I'm going to
correct it for them.
It's 100 by 100.
No idea what that means,
so I'll ignore that.
And then oh, there's
the source of the image.
I've got to download the PNG.
So it's kind of nice, because
it doesn't require JavaScript,
and it's a nice way
to conditionally load
the kind of file that
the browser supports.
We got quite excited about it,
and we were tweeting about it.
The mistake we made
is we did not test it.
So a few of us did just
that, and we found out
something interesting.
All of these
browsers support SVG,
but which browsers will
download the PNG as well?
And I'll give you a clue.
It's not all of them.
Not all of them get it wrong.
It's just one or
some of the browsers
are going to get this
wrong, and they end up
downloading both
the PNG and the SVG.
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
OK, we're saying no in all
the browsers and yes in IE.
It's almost like
you've been burned
by that browser in the past.
Well, the answer
is you are right.
Internet Explorer will make a
request for two images here.
It's because all
modern browsers,
they've got two parsers
built into them.
It's a relatively new
thing for them to have,
but they all have it.
One parser runs ahead, and it
goes, and it tries and finds
things like it should download,
like scripts and images
or whatever.
And the other parser comes along
and does the heavy lifting,
like building the DOM tree,
parsing scripts, et cetera.
And this has a
really large benefit.
A study we did at Google,
we looked at 2,000 sites,
and then we added
this preloader,
and we got a 20%
speed improvement
to get to DOM content loaded,
so it's really useful.
But in order to be
quick, this pre-parser
is a little bit stupid.
And in Internet Explorer, it's
a bit too stupid at the moment.
It gets over excited.
It's like oh, look, I'm
going to show this PNG.
I'm going to show this PNG.
Here I go showing the PNG.
Oh, no, actually, I won't.
It's actually an SVG.
I'll do that instead.
So the main parser sees the
markup and it sees the image,
but it misses the SVG context.
And then the main
parser comes along
and goes why am I
downloading PNG?
And it cancels that download
and goes for the SVG instead.
But by that point, it's
made the connection.
It's probably got all of
the image by that point.
The moral here is don't
trust performance tips.
Make sure you test things.
At Chrome we say "tools,
not rules," which rhymes,
so I guess it must be true.
But always be on the lookout for
existing data or existing tests
that you can run.
One of my favorite stories
in science, or a tale,
I don't know how
true it is but it
involves this man,
August Weismann.
And he wanted to disprove
that life experience was
part of evolution, like
something that happened
to you during your life would
be passed down as evolution.
So the way he was
going to disprove
this is he took two mice,
and he cut their tails off
and bred them together.
And then he took
the offspring there,
and he cut their tails off
and bred them together.
The idea was we shouldn't
end up with mice
being born without tails, right?
And he was running
this test for quite a
while until one of his
colleagues pointed out, August,
you do realize that Jewish
people have been inadvertently
carrying out this experiment
a lot longer than you have.
Oh, yeah.
So he stopped his test, and
he just used that as evidence.
So what about this?
We've got a div.
It's displaying non
as an image inside it.
So the image won't be
displayed, but which browsers
are going to download it anyway?
So yeah, it's not
going to render.
So you could say it was a
waste of bytes to do so.
Or maybe some browser's
going to get it just
in preparation, thinking
it might be shown.
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
OK, we're sort of leaning
towards yes for every browser.
We're quite certain it's going
to happen in Internet Explorer.
The answer, collectively
you are correct.
Yes, all of the
browsers here are
going to download that image.
And this behavior
is part of the spec.
So in the browser in the
beginning, there is nothing,
and then the browser gets
sprayed with HTML text.
And it will convert that
text into a tree of elements
that we know as the DOM.
When is this is HTML?
When an element is
turned into-- when
a tag is turned into an
element, the construction steps
for that element have run.
And for image, it's really
complicated, actually,
creating an image element.
But step 14 down
here at the bottom
is where it actually makes the
request and requests the image,
so visibility doesn't
matter at all.
It doesn't come into it.
And that's kind of
good, because it
means that your images can
download before your CSS is
downloaded, before your
scripts have downloaded.
As a downside, it meant that
responsive images polyfills did
not work because by the
time your JavaScript gets
to the image, it's
already started
to download the thing
that was there already.
You're just going to
add a second download
by changing the source.
This won't be a
problem in the future.
The resource priority
spec we've specified
the postpone attribute,
which tells an image that it
shouldn't display if
it's displaying non,
among other things.
But what if we are using CSS?
What then?
So here we've got a div
that's displaying non,
and inside there's a div
with a background image.
So it's kind of similar
to the image one.
But we saw that images
are ignoring CSS,
but here we're actually
in CSS land already.
So are there any browsers that
are going to download that,
or are they just
going to ignore it?
Because once again, it's
not going to be displayed.
So you could consider
it a waste of bytes.
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
We're kind of edging towards
yes in every browser.
I'm afraid not.
No browsers are going to
download it here, none at all.
And that's kind
of-- I suppose you
could see that as a good thing.
It's saving bytes.
But what if we did this?
Similar question.
It's a div displaying non,
and it has a background image.
The difference in
the last question
is it's all on one element.
It's not-- the image isn't
inside another element that's
displaying non.
Does that change things?
Once again, it's not going to
need that background image.
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
We're edging towards
yes in every browser.
A little bit more
confident in Chrome.
Most browsers will.
Firefox will not.
So what's going on here?
Once the browser has
this tree of elements,
it needs to work out
what they look like
and where they go on the page.
And the first step of this
is a style calculation.
So it calculates all the styles.
It goes through the
CSS cascade, the style
attributes, the font tags
if you're from the '90s.
And works out what style
applies to each element.
But not everything gets
its style calculated,
so this div up at the top
turned out to be displaying non.
The browser stops there.
It doesn't calculate
for the children,
because those elements
have no impact
on the rendering of the page.
So it short cuts.
So if these elements
have a background image,
the browser just never
finds out about it.
This div up at the top
here is displaying non,
but it did have its
style calculated in order
to find that out.
And that's when the browser will
discover the background image.
Firefox is a little bit smarter
here and avoids the download.
But if you change that to,
instead of displaying non,
you use visibility
hidden or opacity zero,
Firefox would download as well.
Who's getting it right
according to the specification?
Everyone is.
The spec is really vague here.
It says the browser
may optimize,
even if the element
is just obscured
or it's underneath another one.
But no browsers are that smart.
This kind of freedom
in specifications
is kind of good,
because it means
the browser can do
the right thing given
the device, the connectivity,
maybe even the battery percent,
how much battery
you've got left.
But it's also scary,
because it means
you're going to get the browsers
doing different things as they
try new stuff with
that freedom they have.
But I think that
kind of diversity
is what makes the web great.
It's not one company driving
forward with its own interests.
It's lots of companies
driving forward
in different directions.
And we get this kind of car
crash, but with a happy ending.
And that's the web
that we have today.
If you want to avoid
downloading a CSS background,
hiding an element isn't enough.
You need to put it inside an
element that is displaying non.
But when you do
this, you're just
relying on what
browsers do today.
It's not specified behavior.
Browsers may change.
The only sure-fire way is
make sure the browser doesn't
find out about that
background image.
Don't add the class name
that adds that background.
Or don't add the
element to the DOM
at all until you really need it.
OK, things have
been relatively easy
so far because we weren't
involving JavaScript.
So let's get
JavaScript involved.
What about this?
I'm creating an image,
I'm giving it a source.
I'm not putting it
in the document,
and I'm spelling "image"
incorrectly like we did before.
So we saw in HTML that it
was also correcting I-M-A-G-E
to I-M-G. But does it
do the same in the DOM?
Do images even download when
they're not in the document?
Because once again,
this is not--
the browser doesn't
need to render this yet,
or it can't render this yet.
I'm going to close the
question three, two, one.
This is the point in the
quiz where the audience just
gets broken, and the
needles just drift
towards the center of I
don't know what's going on.
In this case, most
browsers will download.
Firefox won't, and
there are three parts
to this explanation.
As we saw before,
the DOM gets parsed,
and the creation steps
of the elements are run.
This animation took
me a long time,
which is why you've
seen it three times
already, but that
is the last time.
But when an element is
created using DOM stuff,
it's still going to
run the creation steps,
and we solve for
images in step 14.
That is going to be when
it downloads the image.
We can use this
to our advantage,
because this one line, you
can make a "get" request
to anything that the
machine can access.
And in fact, images have
their own DOM constructor,
unlike a lot of other elements.
So that tiny bit
of code: instant
get request to anywhere else.
And this is pretty much how
Google Analytics talks back
to the server.
But we saw before that Firefox
didn't make the request,
so what's going on there?
When we create this, most
browsers-- Chrome, Safari, IE--
will give us an HTML image
element back, whereas Firefox
will give us an HTML element.
It's not an image.
If you add it to the page,
it won't display an image.
And the interesting
thing is here,
it's the only one
getting it right.
We saw before, this
is how the browser
or how the spec
deals with images
that are spelled incorrectly.
But this is in the
parsing spec, and we
bypassed parsing by
using create element,
completely bypassing the parser.
So it should-- Firefox
gives us an HTML element.
It should give us an
HTML unknown element,
which it does if you do
create an element fubar.
Firefox is doing something
special for these images.
But it's getting it more
right than other browsers.
I think I preferred it when we
were developing for browsers.
It was like there
was one bad guy,
and it was Internet
Explorer 6 or 7 or 8.
And all the other browsers
seemed perfect in comparison.
But I see the browser-scape as
being like an orchestra where
Internet Explorer
8 was just this kid
hitting two cymbals
together and screaming.
But once we finally kick
the screaming child out
of the room, and we come back
and we start conducting again,
we realize oh,
everyone is actually
a little bit out of tune.
We just didn't realize because
of the screaming cymbal child
of Internet Explorer.
So let's just get CSS involved
again, but JavaScript as well.
What about this?
I'm creating a div,
giving it a background.
It's not in the document,
but everything's
spelled right and valid.
We saw images download
at this point,
but what about when
CSS is involved?
Are we going to see
things download there?
Get your answers in quickly.
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
Once again, the
needles are starting
to drift into the middle.
The answer here is no.
No browsers will download here.
This is the same as
the display non case.
The browser won't calculate
the style of elements
that display non, and
it also won't calculate
the styles of
elements that aren't
in the document, because
there's no point.
It doesn't affect the
rendering of the page at all.
OK, I'm going to be cruel now.
What about this?
So same again.
I'm adding it to the document.
Then I'm removing it again.
Is it in the document long
enough for the browser
to go oh, I should download
this background image?
Or does it not get to
see it long enough?
Does it not bother?
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
OK, we're suggesting
yes because yes, it
has entered the document.
I'm afraid you are all
wrong with that one, all
the people who said that.
The browser doesn't want to
think about styles or layout
until the very last moment.
And that's normally
rendering, when it actually
needs to change
pixels on the screen.
And we can't do that,
or we don't do that,
while we're in the
middle of JavaScript.
So the browser
actually sits back
and waits for that
JavaScript block to execute.
And then afterwards it will
go and look at what's changed
and react to that when
it needs to render next.
But does this change that?
So same code again, but in
between adding and removing it
to the document,
I'm going to ask
for the text content
of the element.
Now, the text content is
going to be an empty string,
because it is an empty element.
But is just accessing
that property
going to change things?
I'm not even assigning
it to a variable.
Is it just even going to be
optimized away by JavaScript
because it has no impact?
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
Almost dead in the middle.
Excellent.
The answer is no.
No browsers will make a request.
Getting the text
content is easy.
It's just going to go through
the DOM, find the text nodes,
concatenate the values together.
What about this?
Similar question, but this
time enter HTML rather than
text content.
Once again, it's going to be
an empty string that comes back
there, because the
element is empty.
But does it behave
differently to text content?
Are the browsers going to
do something different?
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
We're saying no here.
Well, you're mostly right.
Internet Explorer will
make a download here.
And the reason for that is
because in Internet Explorer--
I don't know.
I have absolutely no idea.
Some things in the world
cannot be explained,
and this is one of them.
Like how it takes three
attempts to plug in a USB cable,
even though there are
only two possibilities,
some things cannot be explained.
OK, on the same theme again,
but this time in the text.
Once again, like
the other two, this
is going to come back as an
empty string, because it's
an empty element.
But is that going to
behave differently?
Is Internet Explorer still
going to make the request
erroneously, like it did before?
Is it going to get
it correct this time?
Who knows?
I'm going to close the
question in three, two, one.
We're edging towards no.
Little bit less sure
on Internet Explorer.
The answer: yes.
Most browsers will
make a request here.
And this actually kind of
makes sense in an odd way.
Let's make a div.
It's got a background image,
and it's got some inner HTML.
It's got Hello World inside
it, but World is inside
a div of its own.
We add it to the document.
We ask for its text content.
It's Hello World,
but when we ask
for the inner text in,
i.e., Safari and Chrome,
it's going to return this.
It's got a line
break in the middle.
And the reason for this is inner
text isn't just a text content.
It's more like
what you would get
if you copied-- if you
highlighted the element
and copied it.
And because of this, it's
got style information,
because the World is
on a different line,
because the div is block level.
Or it is by default,
and it is in this case.
So what actually happens
here is the browser--
we asked for the text content.
It just gets that back, but
when you ask for the inner text,
the browser has to go Ah!
I need to know what the
layout of this element
is in order to return this.
I need to find out if that
div's block level, where am I
going to put my line breaks?
Oh, look, there's a
background image there.
And then it downloads
it, because it
forces it to look at the styles.
Most of the time,
the browser will
defer looking at styles
as late as it can.
But here we forced
it to happen sooner,
because we've
asked for something
that's style dependent.
Firefox didn't make
a request, because it
doesn't support inner text.
It doesn't support
the property at all,
so that's just undefined.
That was quite cruel.
But if we used any
of these properties,
like out of text--
not out of text,
but offset left,
offset parens, Firefox
would have made the
request as well.
So ignorance of
those elements that
will require style information,
that's one of the number
one problems with performance
that we see on the web.
Because also you can do
some nice hackery with it.
If you look at code like this,
it looks really expensive,
but it's not.
It's really cheap,
because the browser's just
going to sit back and
watch you just writing
this property to an object.
And it's not going to care
about it until that block ends.
And once that's all done, it
will just look at the results,
and in this case, there's
no pixel difference.
This can lead to some
unexpected results, not just
graphical performance, but--
So imagine-- let's have a
look at a practical example.
Here is Paul Lewis and me.
We work together.
We want to go over there.
You can tell, because
we're pointing.
Let's do it with code.
We're going to say left 0%,
going to set a transition,
and then left 100%.
We run that code.
Hey, off we go.
Excellent.
We win at code.
But if we run that code
again, nothing happens.
And the reason
nothing happens is
the browser's going to batch
up these style changes.
So we've got-- we're
setting "left" twice,
but the browser's only going
to listen to the last one.
And we're essentially
saying transition to 100%,
but we're already at
100%, so it doesn't move.
You might have
encountered this and tried
to fix it with set timeouts in
an arbitrary number in there.
But what you actually want
to do is at this point,
just after we set
the first left,
you want the browser to
go look at that style
and actually think about it.
And we can actually do that by
putting one of those properties
in: offset width or whatever.
And once we do that, we can
run that code as many times
as we want, and it
will work every time.
But you are relying on
unspecified behavior
when you do that.
The web animations API
will save us there.
And just before I
get kicked off stage,
I want to go through
the bad side of that.
Normally, using things
that offset width
in the middle of
your code can lead
to a performance difficulty.
And here's an example of that.
Here I've got a page with
a load of paragraphs.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to set Chrome's timeline
recording, which
is going to record
everything that's going on,
resize this green box, and
I'm going to hit that button.
When I hit that button,
all of these paragraphs
are going to become the
same size as the green box.
So do that, press the
button, and they all change.
And that was quite slow.
We can see in the timeline
there's a little spike there.
And if we have a look at the
number that comes up there,
it's 1.27 seconds.
It's very slow.
But this is the little
Warning icon on there,
and if we look into that, we
get a clue of what's going on.
We get this recalculate style
layout, recalculate style
layout happening
over and over again,
and that's not looking great.
The code we're using
is really simple.
We just looped through
all of those paragraphs
and set the offset width of the
green block to the paragraph.
Now, the first time we
go through this loop,
we ask the browser what is
the size of the green box?
And it goes oh, I
know the answer,
because I've just drawn it.
Here's your answer.
Easy peasy.
And then we set the
width of the paragraph.
But the next time we
come around the loop,
we ask the browser what's
the width of the green box?
And it's like hmm,
I used to know
the answer to that question,
but since then you've
been playing around
with styles on the page.
So I need to go away and have a
think about what you've changed
and see if it affects the
width of the green block.
And that's going to
happen on every loop.
This is layout thrashing.
This is interleaving
style reads and writes,
and it's a performance killer.
What we actually want to
do is just cache that,
do the reads first outside the
loop, get the green box width,
and then go through the loop.
And the difference is
absolutely astounding.
So recording that, changing
the width of the green box,
click the button, it
just happens instantly,
and it's a massive difference.
And that was like
60 milliseconds
all in for everything,
versus over a second.
So if you need to read something
that's style dependent,
do it before you start
making style changes.
Am I out of time?
Am I done?
OK, but before we do that, we'll
have a look at the final scores
and see who managed
to win the Chromecast.
If I can get my mouse
pointer over here.
Right.
A moment of tension.
Where's my mouse pointer?
Let's see if this works.
OK.
Oh, we've got a draw.
That's how many?
We've got one Chromecast.
We can get another one.
That's excellent.
And I do have a bonus round,
but we're definitely out time.
Where are you two people?
Where are you?
Oh, one here, and there--
Oh, congratulations, guys.
A round of applause
for these guys.
And with that, I say
thank you very much,
and I'm going to make
way for someone else.
Thank you very much, guys.
Cheers.